hi everyone thank you for coming here so
today I want to talk to you about my
approach for making data visualization
simpler especially when talking about
more complex graphs it's a bit of my
motivation for this talk so I work as a
data scientist in product analytics at
Babel which is language learning app and
in my role I have to daily communicate
with a lot of different people some of
them technical some of them less
technical and I have to explain to them
stories usually about our learners data
and fortunately or not this these
stories are actually usually quite
complicated so we have users who are
doormen who are super active who are in
different devices at the same time and
when I have to kind of visualize this
information in a graphical way often it
becomes kind of a mess in my head how do
I go about visualizing this complexity
so the key challenge that I face is how
do I make a chart really that is complex
and meaning yet in my code and its
implementation is simple to understand
for me and so what's on today's menu
first they'll talk to you about the
grammar of graphics and specifically
about the layered grammar of graphics
Jews as we saw in the previous
presentation this is a topic that is
kind of related to G G plots in R then
I'll talk about implementations in
Python and specifically the ones that I
look to you'd like to use and finally
I'll give you a little bit of how I use
the grammar as a mindset not just in
terms of its implementation as a package
in any language but just as a mindset
that will help me to frame graphics in a
more concise way so what is the grammar
of graphics it's basically a tool set of
rules a framework whatever you want to
call it that allows us to describe
graphics in the more logical way in a
more structured way a a little bit about
the history so 2006 there's this great
book by Leland Wilkinson the grammar of
graphics versus ver dense very
go kind of establishes what the basic
elements of a graphic are I'm sure data
transformation element scales guides and
coordinates and I'll talk about these in
a second more but when we talk about the
layered grammo graphics so key takeaway
would now have kind of these rules
established on what gram of graphics is
then entered 2010 Hadley Wickman that we
also heard about before kind of a cult
figure in the art community comes out
with this paper and the package did you
plot to where he explains how do we take
the theory from Wilkinson or how do we
create a package out of it you know how
do we actually code these layers and
these different elements in this paper I
found really cool I really recommend you
read it actually if you like
visualization he describes how to plot
this chart which is a sort of famous
chart by Menards he plotted it by hand
in 1869 I think this is the progression
of French troops towards Moscow in red
and the Holly to retreat it and this is
just look at it this looks like a really
complex graphic how would you go about
plotting this and he makes it very very
simple to understand
if you understand the structural
elements that make up this plot you
would go about coding it in X way so why
are the actual components I will quickly
go through a little bit the theoretical
part there's no code involved and later
I'll talk about the packages that I like
so a component components of a layer and
I'm always referring to the layer
grammar of graphics more this paper we
have our dates our ascetic geometries
and statistics and I'll explain in a
second what they are exactly and these
are kind of the mandatory the core
elements of every of every layer then we
have facets and coordinates and symptom
scales or scale manipulations that can
belong to multiple layers and finally we
have themes are usually globalism more
like the visual elements that are not
related to the data so let's go one by
one the first thing ingredient we need
our data so I'll walk you through this
by looking a little bit at the by using
as an example the diamond dataset this
is very typical data set used when
learning about it
visualization it basically has a bunch
of diamonds the price the different cuts
the size karats is the size the cut is
kind of the quality and then you have
all these other dimensions it's a good
mix of categorical a numeric data to
play around with different realizations
important next ingredient are the
aesthetics so aesthetics are essentially
mappings between the variables and our
data to the visual properties of the
graph so for example when we're talking
about a scatter plot scatter plot has a
dot in a Cartesian plane and we have to
match every elements of our data frame
of our data sets our variable to a
certain element of that visual scatter
plot right so scatter plot has every dot
has an x position a y position and
perhaps we can add color to it right or
a size of the dot so the will say in
this case we will map the price of the
Diamonds to the x to y axis the carrots
to the x axis and the color of the
diamond to the color of the dots on our
on our graph then comes geometries and
geometries are really what we think
about when we say oh this type of charts
so when we say a line plot a scatter
plot a histogram a violin plot all of
these are essentially geometries and
geometries are very interesting because
they implying them a lot of other things
that we talked about the data so for
example line plots as a geometry already
implies in it the kind of visual
elements we can map our data to right so
it implies we have an x position Y
position a thickness of the line the
color of the line right a histogram has
bins or bin sizes etc statistical
transformations are not directly
intuitive I'll try to illustrate with an
example there are basically
manipulations of our data of our
original data that have to happen so
that we can map it to this visual
element on the on a screen or on paper
so if we look again at only the cuts or
the quality of the diamond and the price
we can actually aggregate this data in
different ways right if we just looked
at the raw data observation by
observation this wouldn't want to one
translate to
barplot that shows us the average price
right we have to aggregate based on the
cuts and take make some kind of
statistical transformations so that's
the mean and the same goes for the
median for example another very obvious
example is a box plot so a box plot
takes the raw data and it calculates the
median the quartiles the whisker is
right to tell where the outliers are so
these are all manipulations to our data
they're done implicitly when we think
about a specific type of geometry and so
what about some additional elements to a
graphic that are not necessary to
formulate so we have scales and scales
for me this is probably the hardest
layer to understand because scales would
have to do the different elements of the
plot or the graphic that we try to map
our data to so for example we can map as
we said our data to a numerical value
right so a value on the x-axis and
y-axis but we can also plot it we can
also map it to a color or shape or size
of a dot and so scales determine how the
data and our real data set are mapped to
this kind of linear or color space so
for example here we take the sides
versus we're trying to look at the size
of the diamond versus the price on the
top we're just looking at the raw dates
and the bottom we make a log
transformation on the x-axis perhaps to
see the relationship a little bit better
and this is a this is a transformation
in terms of the scales we scales are
also if we map color for example we have
to tell what is the minimum and the
maximum value of the color range that
we're talking about right if a color is
discrete we want to say what is bad what
is good right what is the red what does
a green one mean and legends are in fact
kind of inverse decoding of a scale then
facets facets are we use facets to in a
way slice our data based on some kind of
categorical variable that is not
explicitly shown in our plots so for
example if we're talking about again the
size of the diamond versus the price
we plot them when we get some kind of
the trend right we say all right we see
some kind of positive relationship but
does the same relationship halt if we
change the type of the diamond is that
the type of the quality of the diamond
so we take an external primer which is
not included in the first graph right we
take the cut of the diamond fair good
very good premium ideal and we split our
data based on that but we plot them on a
common chart so the one on the right is
it one chart I mean it has subplots but
it's really telling one story then we
have our coordinate system I guess this
one is sort of basic most people see we
have our Cartesian coordinates usually
and polar coordinates you can plot the
same type of data in a Cartesian space
where polar space and finally we have
the steam which is really everything
else that doesn't have to do directly
with the data so for example annotations
titles the fonts we use etcetera
importantly theme is really what allows
us to tell an economists plot from xkcd
plots even if the data is exactly the
same is the theme that makes it feel
like that I found this really nice
animation that I think kind of helps put
it all together that's we put each
elements of the layers together and all
of them when they are you know layered
on top of each other creates the graphic
now what about implementations in Python
so I'll start with a little side note
which is that there are actually a lot
of libraries out there in Python that
are at least a little bit inspired by
the grammar of graphics I think before
someone mentioned Altair there's
actually a great talk from last year's
PI Conde talking about grammar of
graphics and I'll tear specifically and
also bokya says that it's kind of a
little bit inspired by grammar of
graphics but today I'll talk to you
about two other packages that I actually
personally use and maybe we'll just try
to uncover how the grammar of graphics
reveals itself there so
one is plot 9 and plot 9 especially from
someone coming originally from art like
me is really neat because it's a direct
implementation of ggplot and the ggplot
syntax in Python so plot 9
well you just a pip install plot 9 from
plot 9 import everything and then use
the usual ggplot syntax and I will
explain in a second how everything maps
so for this example I'll use this
Pokemon data set from Cargill it's
really neat it's a data set of 800 known
pokemons to man with all of these
different characteristics about their
skills in terms of defense attack speeds
HP has a lot of other variables and then
the type the Pokemon belongs to and its
legendary status hopefully it'll help
you choose the best Pokemon starter
program so how does it work first we
start with a data so plot 9 uses the
same kind of additive syntax the GG plot
does we start with creating a GG plot
object and plot 9 is also based it takes
its fundamentals from matplotlib so it
tries to kind of map all this the
premises of my cloud lib to more ggplot
like syntax so we start by defining our
data's our data is the pokemon data
frame and then we define our geometry
and geometries are defined by adding
geometry underscore whatever geometry
you want so you add you can have a point
which is scatter flawed bar density area
histogram box plots violin whatever you
want and then we start adding our
aesthetics and aesthetics
like we said before they are tied to the
geometry right so a line plot will have
different possible aesthetics then let's
say a bar plot or histogram right so
here we map the aesthetics of on the x
axis of this bar plot we want to split
our data based on the type that the
pokemon belongs to so we have this bug
grass normal so we have the counts of
each pokemons in each group
then what if we want to do statistical
transformations so there's two ways both
in ggplot and plotlines to do this
statistical transformations can be
defined either outside as a separate you
know additive element or inside the
geometry here I personally prefer it's
more intuitive for me to define it
inside so we say for this geometry a
column geometry I want to make
statistical transformation called
summary which is the average so here
we're looking again at the here we're
looking inside of the count of pokémon's
based on their time looking at how well
do the performance term of their attack
so the average attack strength how about
coordinates coordinates unfortunately
because plot nine is an implementation
of ggplot in python not everything means
yet there you're of course welcome to go
to project and contribute but for
example if you want to plot your
pokémon's in the pie charts in a plot
nine you wouldn't be able to do that
because we don't have the polar
coordinates and then we have facets
let's take a step back and say okay I
want to look at how the attack capacity
of these pokemons is distributed is
split between legendary non legendary
and how this different really how big
this difference is based on the type of
the Pokemon type so we facet on the
Pokemon type we keep fixed scale so we
can compare each facets element to each
other and then inside each plot we have
kind of the density distribution of the
attack skill of the Pokemon mmm
interestingly so for me as I said scales
are a little bit hard to understand and
especially when we talk about color
because it's not something I guess that
intuitive so here we have one aesthetic
that we have is the fill right so it's a
color that we give to each distribution
and the fill is really it it is a map it
is mapped to the data it's mapped to
fact whether pokemons legend or not and
since it's map to the data it also has a
scale so the scale of the fill can be
also manipulated so for example when we
say that not legendary pokemons are
green and legendary are pink we're
defining the scale of this color
dimension and this is a different scale
right
finally themes are defined again as
external parameters you can I mean you
can create this object right because
it's based on MATLAB and add whatever
aesthetic elements you want afterwards
but this is there's also some predefined
themes that come in they're kind of nice
not this next is totally Express and
totally Express is a high-level wrapper
basically around totally I think it came
out in March this year and we use it in
my team people like it that's the whole
premise of flatly Express is that you
can make really complex graphs in one
line of code interactive so you import
plotly Express as px and plotly Express
is directly inspired by layer grammar
graphics you can find that in the
documentation and the whole focus of the
package is conciseness I don't know if
you've ever used plotly before but it's
often like there's different syntaxes
that you could use often you get lost in
these endless traces or list
comprehensions etcetera and flatly
Express tries to get rid of this so the
basic way that applauded Lee Express
object maps to the grammar of graphics
is the following so we starts with
creating an instance of the class that
represents the geometry so px dot
scatter is the object and the geometry
that we want to plot we want to plot a
scatter plot then we have data frames XY
color size all of these are aesthetics
but some of them can also be linked to
the scale that they represent so we have
the x limit y limit color minimum
etcetera and finally we have the facets
so let's go through this example here
we're gonna talk about this
the Gapminder dates a Gapminder
foundation collects data about different
socio-economic indicators around in
different countries around the world
mm-hmm
and here we're gonna talk about
specifically GDP per capita versus life
expectancy in 2007 this is a nice
example because allows us to have
there's multiple dimensions can be
mapped to different features of the plot
and we'll see how that goes in plots
Express so we start by defining our
geometry the first thing you really have
to choose is the geometry you wanna plot
so geometries are you can choose or
scatter bar or PLAs parallel coordinates
anything you want there's a there's a
lot of different geometries you can
choose from then you choose you put in
as a parameter your data and you specify
the mapping of your aesthetics to to the
to the data in your data set I think you
dimension before that tidy data is
really net well it's kind of necessary
and very tied to the ggplot anti diverse
universe and I think plotly Express is
also kind of build around this tie well
you kind of have to use a tidy data set
to make it work better so let's say here
we define four different aesthetics the
X that mentioned the Y that's what the
position on the x axis positional y-axis
the color of the bubble and the size of
the bubble and those are mapped to
different variables now we have scales
something you saw before is that it's
kind of hard to see the difference
between the bubble sizes and the reason
really is that the just isn't yeah the
reason really is that package
automatically kind of scales your data
and the way it scaled it before it
wasn't possible to see it so what we
want to do is we want to adjust the
scale so we adjust the size
of the bubbles to a certain maximum so
we set the limit and we make it a little
bit more visual more visually
interpretable and then we also want to
make a log transformation to the x-axis
also very easy to do inside of the
parameters which allows us again to see
better kind of this relationship between
GDP per capita and life expectancy
statistical transformations employee
express are implicit in the type of
geometry that you choose you can't
necessarily plot and define them
directly so in the example of a box plot
your plot Express will go there and
calculate the median the quantiles the
whisker is etc if you want to do any
other kind of statistical
transformations you would have to do
them beforehand or outside of the
plotting function facets are also very
easily defined and coordinates are also
inbuilt same as the statistical
transformations are in built-in the type
of geometry that you choose so this is
some different data but it shows you
like what kind of you can build a polar
bar plot very easily and finally themes
are the themes that inherited from plot
leave default themes since you are using
plotly essentially you can always go and
define your own themes you can create
whatever kind of ascetic space you want
so these are kind of two different seems
so as a summary plot mix press allows
you to build interactive plots in one
line of code so this is I forgot to put
the quote that this is just one line of
code to say this is going back to the
pokémons we can see how their HP score
is dependent on the type the first type
the second type of generation and their
legendary sets so finally just very
shortly I'll give an example of how I
use the grammar just as a mind sets a
big disclaimer is that I actually really
liked math clip I always use meta loop
to mix that six lots because I think
it's very flexible allows you to create
high-quality plots that are you know
very adjustable to
you want and so my philosophy is to
still use the grammar of graphics as a
mindset and then map everything I have
in metal flip to that so as a challenge
let's try to build this data for it this
chart in Matt Butler so this was done in
plotly Express I mean this was
originally an interactive chart you can
save it as a static one let's try to
build this in that top lip so what I
would do is I would take the elements of
the grammar of graphics and I would
think about each of them okay in this
case what do i what does each element
translates to my use case and where
exactly in matplotlib am i gonna find it
so geometry is a scatter plot right we
this is easy method lip I plot scatter
great what about the aesthetics
aesthetics are also defined inside the
scatter plot there the X parameter the y
vs the C so we say in our date so the X
will be the GDP etc scales this really
depends right so matter clip is really
great it's allowing us to adjust
numerical scales but in terms of color
scales for example or the sizes of the
bubbles those are things that would
probably have to be done manually so in
this case I'll show you in a second I
actually went ahead and I trimmed the
population just divided it by 200,000 to
make it fit in the scale of the bubble
chart facets in MATLAB are really a way
you have to kind of iterate through
these subplots and populate them
independently it's a little bit ugly but
I guess this is a method Lib syntax and
finally themes are also you kind of have
to think about what is it exactly that
you want to do for example in this case
colors that were dependent on the facet
that you're in
so since we're talking about subplots
you have to like take the color you want
and put it inside each so this is the
outcome this is where we have partly
expressed with plot L'Express on the
Left would map the lip on the right and
this is yeah this is the amount of code
it took to do this in math let live
because you had to iterate through every
single subplot and this is the amount of
code it took in plot in a plot C Express
and as you can see I actually used plot
Lee to update the layout because I
wanted to remove those legends in the
answer it's not one line of code in situ
so that's it thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you um are there any questions yes
thank you very much it was very good if
just one question might be a little bit
specific but in Claude Lee Express you
have those hovers and so if you hover
over one point yeah I'm just wondering
do you know any way to edit the hovers
because sometimes it might be nice to
show a picture or anything have you an
experience I don't know but I think you
will have to use the underlying plotly
syntax to fix these kind of things I
found flatly Express to be quite
restrictive in general so for simple
things it's great for editing things
okay thanks thanks for the great talk so
I found myself often using this more
complicated more higher-level plotting
libraries which you introduced here or
Seabourn or like this but then returning
back to my plot because I need to really
have a fine control over every features
do you have any idea how I can and start
off with this more higher-level library
but then do the fine-tuning only just
inside map ellipse so how I can
integrate these two different levels of
libraries or should I just start off
using my palate and do everything by
myself it's a great question and I think
about it all the time I don't know if I
have an answer in my experience I will
usually try to build something like with
Seaborn right because I'm hoping that it
will give me the result I want but then
I realized okay
for smaller details and fine tuning I
have to actually adjust them perhaps if
you actually thought about this if every
time that we built a graph we kind of
took a step back and we said all right
we want these elements like regardless
of code we just want these elements and
then we say all right do all of these
elements exist in Seabourn then an easy
way and then go ahead and do it
otherwise I think it's actually maybe
better to learn to do math let live very
well sorry first of all thank you for
the presentation really really cool
insights but I it's here in front so we
use data visualizations to break down
complex problems on a daily basis but I
so there's a lot of abundance of types
of data visualizations that we can do
with all these packages but I was
wondering when do you actually is there
framework that you use if you wanna show
like visualize problem or something is
there for a framework that's used to
choose which type of data visualization
and taking in consideration the the
people that you're trying to present
this for also the data literacy that
they have for example some of these data
type visualization types can be a bit
more advanced yeah or a little a little
bit more and that it can lead to bias or
some so is there where framework that
you use and what are the most common
types of the devil ization
visualizations that you opted for thank
you
great question so actually I do have a
sort of framework that I like it comes
from I guess I maybe I wouldn't call it
framework but there's this book called
visual storytelling with data but coal
NASA I can't pronounce her name
I think it's considered like a very
important book and
more modern way of thinking about the
divisional addition it goes really into
detail about okay first you have to like
think about your audience this is the
first thing before you even start
plotting anything and then she
progresses to explain okay how do
different types Dimitri's write
different types of visualizations are
better for explaining different problems
and the simpler actually usually the
better regardless of what your audiences
then again there's a difference in terms
of if you're building a visualization
that is explore explorative or
explanatory explore through explanatory
right so an interactive visualization
like the person could go in and play
around and do whatever they want like a
dashboard but if you want to make a
point it's a very different questions
like for in a presentation right you
want to highlight one line out of many I
really recommend that book but in terms
of visualizations that I in network we
use the most usually it's actually the
simplest ones like line plots we use
histograms a lot you should look at that
time that user it takes users to do
different things and but we rarely go
into more complex statistical ones like
I've only ever done I don't know some
kind of density function to just
demonstrate statistical concepts but not
actually to model or to display our data
so I think simplicity is in the end much
much better in a work environment in a
business in Rome oh thanks for this
comparison of those high level api's so
much not all the data is can always fit
into a data frame like structurally
maybe it's parse time series also so
which of these plotting libraries is
most useful when you cannot put your
data into a single data frame I don't
know the answer to that sorry
okay sadly time is up for further
questions you have to take them offline
so thanks again thank you very much
[Applause]